Speaker 1: All right, we're going to look
at something fascinating today.
This is the best confrontational interview
that Donald Trump has ever done.
And you were going to see Steve Inskeep from
NPR dismantle each lie that Trump tells, and
you will see firsthand what happens when a
real interviewer is placed in a position where
he or she can actually counteract Trump's
lies.
This interview that I'm going to play for
you here.
This is a slow moving train wreck the Jonathan
Swan interview on Axios with Trump, where
Trump held up maps and charts and said, But
you can't do that, sir.
That was like a rapid train wreck.
This is a slow moving train wreck where each
claim trumps make.
Each claim Trump makes is refuted with fact
by Steve Inskeep, and eventually Trump just
hangs up the phone.
Trump aborts the interview because it is going
so poorly.
Each time he's confronted, he moves on to
another topic.
I'm going to keep track of all the different
claims so that then we can actually add them
up.
Beautifully done by Steve Inskeep.
Let's just jump right in.
Speaker 5: Just have to point out Doug Logan
to name one of the states that you just named.
Doug Logan, who ran the audit in Arizona that
was set up by your allies, didn't find serious
problems.
This is a quote.
The ballots that were provided to us to count
in the Coliseum very accurately correlate
with the official canvass number.
He raised a bunch of administrative issues,
but didn't find a problem that would have
changed the result at all.
Speaker 6: The ballots may correspond, but
look at the ballots themselves.
The number of ballots doesn't mean anything.
It's who signed the ballots.
Whether the ballots come from what you really
have to do in that report is look at the findings
and the findings are devastating for Arizona.
They're devastating like nobody's seen before.
Why did other states are just as bad?
Speaker 5: Why did Republican officials in
Arizona accept the results then?
Speaker 6: Because they're rhino's, and frankly,
a lot of people are questioning that.
Why would they?
They fought very hard.
The Maricopa County
Speaker 1: that's claim to.
Don't worry, I'm keeping track and then we'll
review.
This is this is fascinating.
Speaker 6: People and people don't understand
it because all you have to do is look at the
findings and just see, you know, some of those
people went before Congress a short while
ago and they were grilled by Congressman Biggs.
You ought to take a look at their testimony.
They weren't able to answer anything.
He made them look like fools.
They couldn't answer a thing.
They got up and gave a beautiful statement.
And then when it came time to ask Why this?
Why that?
What about these votes?
What about those votes?
They looked like total fools.
Speaker 5: Let me read you some short quotes.
The first is by one of the judges, one of
the ten judges you appointed, who ruled on
this.
And there were many judges, but 10 who you
appointed Brett Ludwig U.S. District Court
in Wisconsin, who was nominated by you in
2020.
He's on the bench and he says, quote this
court allowed the plaintiff the chance to
make his case, and he has lost on the merits.
Another quote, Corey Langhorne for your own
campaign attorney in Arizona, November 12,
2020 quote We are not alleging fraud in this
lawsuit.
We are not alleging anyone stealing the election
and also Rudy Giuliani, your lawyer.
Nov 18, 2020 in Pennsylvania.
Quote This is not a fraud case.
Your own lawyers had no evidence of fraud,
they said in court they had no evidence of
fraud claim.
The judges ruled against you every time on
the merits.
Speaker 6: It was too early to ask for fraud
and to talk about fraud.
Rudy said that because of the fact it was
very early with the because that was obviously
at a very, very that was a long time ago to
things that have found out have more than
bore out what people thought and what people
felt and what people found.
When you look at Lang Heffer, I disagree with
him.
As an attorney, I did not think he was a good
attorney to hire.
I don't know what his game is, but I will
just say this.
You look at the findings, you look at the
number of votes, go into Detroit and just
ask yourself, is it true that there are more
votes and there are voters?
Look at Pennsylvania, look at Philadelphia.
Is it true that there were far more votes
than there were voters?
It is not true that there were pretty tough
things that he does not pretty tough problem.
Speaker 5: It is not true that there were
far more votes than voters.
There was an early count.
I've noticed you've talked about this in rallies
and you've said reportedly this is true.
I think even you know that that was an early
report that was corrected later.
Speaker 6: Well, you take a look at it, really
take a look at Detroit.
In fact, they even had a hard time getting
people to sign off on it because it was so
out of balance they called it out of balance.
So you take a look at it.
You know the real truth, Steve, and this election
was a rigged election.
Speaker 5: Why is it that you think that the
vast majority of your allies in the United
States Senate are not standing behind you?
We did have that statement by Mike Rounds
Speaker 6: because Mitch McConnell is a loser.
And frankly, Mitch McConnell, if he were on
the other side and if Schumer were put in
his position, he would have been fighting
this like you've never seen before.
He would have been fighting this.
I hope you
Speaker 1: guys are taking notes like I am,
Speaker 6: because when you look at it and
this is long is a long way from over.
You take.
A look at what's going on now in Pennsylvania,
take a look at what's going on in Wisconsin.
You just take a look.
We had a lot of cases where the judges wouldn't
hear him.
We had a case in Nevada that was so good.
You read the papers.
It's impossible.
The judge refused to even listen to it.
We had many cases, in fact, they say, and
I can't testify because it's been through
a lot of systems, a lot of different systems.
But they say and they say very strongly, the
judge is just nobody's really gotten a chance
to look, look at the United States Supreme
Court.
They refused to hear the case.
And you had, like you said, there was no
Speaker 5: standing to get the case.
That's correct.
Can I just tell standing?
Speaker 6: I know no standing.
And the president of the United States supposedly
didn't have standing, either.
So I wanted to file it myself.
They said, Sir, you don't have standing.
I said, So
Speaker 1: I mean, that's true.
You know, if he is not a Pennsylvania voter,
he's not a Wisconsin voter.
OK, we don't need to even focus on that now.
In a second, Trump hangs up because he's just
sick of this minute.
Speaker 6: I'm the president of the United
States.
They just rigged it election.
Hundreds of thousands of votes in different
states.
They just rigged it.
Election.
We got we got a number of votes that I think
you'll agree.
No sitting president has ever gotten a number
of votes that I got.
No, no, that's true.
I have gotten a lot of lot, a sitting president.
Do you?
Nobody believes you think Biden got 80 million
votes.
Speaker 5: I don't believe it's true that
you got more than anything in basement in
the election that disputed.
Speaker 6: How come he couldn't?
Speaker 5: If I can't, Mr. President, Mr.
Speaker 6: President, I ask you this question
how come Biden couldn't attract 20 people
for a crowd?
How come when he went to speak in different
locations, nobody came to watch, but all of
a sudden he got 80 million votes?
Speaker 5: If you'll forgive me, maybe because
the election was about you.
If I can just move on to ask, are you telling
Republicans in 2022 that they must press your
case on the past election in order to create?
Or is that an absolute?
Speaker 6: I'm going to do whatever they want
to do, whatever they have to do, they're going
to do.
But the ones that are smart, the ones that
know you take a look at again, you take a
look at how Carrie Lake is doing running for
governor.
She's very big on this issue.
She's leading by a lot.
People have no idea how big this issue is,
and they don't want it to happen again.
It shouldn't be allowed to happen, and they
don't want it to happen again.
And one of the only way it's not going to
happen again is you have to solve the problem
of the presidential rigged election of 2020.
Mr. President,
Speaker 5: I would like one more question.
I want to ask you about a court hearing yesterday,
and Trump has hung up the judge a meet.
Speaker 1: You know, when he sort of like
Withers away, you know what happens if you
take cotton candy and you put it under water?
That's what happens to Trump under questioning.
He it just there's nothing there.
Fantastically done by Steve Inskeep.
Read through how every argument Trump makes
falls apart.
And he just moves to the next one.
Steve Inskeep says they looked at all.
They looked at the ballots.
The ballots are fine, the counts were fine.
And Trump says, well, the number of ballots
were fine.
But if you looked individually, the ballots
have bogus signatures or they are invalid
in some other way.
So that's the shifting.
That's so it's no longer about the numbers,
but now it's about each individual ballot.
Steve Inskeep says the Republican Party accepted
the results.
And he says those aren't really Republicans.
He says those are rhino.
So the next argument?
Steve Inskeep says lawyers, your lawyers and
judges you appointed say it's fine and that
it is not.
There is no fraud.
And Trump says the lawyers were bad, and at
that time, it was too early to claim fraud.
It was, of course, then the fraud had to be
claimed later.
Steve Inskeep says Pennsylvania and Detroit
trumps in Pennsylvania and Detroit, there
were more votes than voters.
That's just completely untrue, and Steve Inskeep
knows that you can look it up yourself.
It's public.
There were not more votes than voters then.
Steve Inskeep asks, why are your Republican
colleagues in the Senate not standing up for
this?
And he says, Well, Mitch McConnell is a loser.
Wow, OK.
Trump says it's not over in Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin, there's still things happening.
No, there aren't.
Trump says courts haven't actually looked
at the cases.
That's a lie.
63 cases were looked at and dismissed.
Trump says hundreds of thousands of votes
were rigged, so he's kind of going back to
the votes again.
And then he says, how did Biden get 80 million
votes if no one went to his events?
And of course, Biden was being really cautious
at the time because of COVID and wasn't really
doing large events.
So piece by piece, you have nothing.
It evaporates like cotton candy when put under
water and you just have grains of sand there.
Nothing substantial of any of any kind.
Excellent job by Steve Inskeep